okay so um I'm rocking this Michael Kors  very campy suit she ready  I feel like pimp already he's behind you  right now Kris Jenner et come over here  this is everything I didn't even  recognize you when you came on the  carpet where did this come from who are  you where Tommy Hilfiger who was decided  you were gonna be blond  tonight Kylie yes did you want to go did  you borrow awake from Kylie no my my  hairdresser George Serrano went running  in his tracksuit so we figured it out it  was the last minute like craziness this  is your third fourth time at the Met  yeah it's Kim coming because I know the  babies and he does yeah she's she's here  yeah  [Music]  [Applause]